welcome to the man of recaps this is
better call saul season five as always
the season begins with a black and white
scene from the future after the events
of breaking bad where saul goodman has
changed his identity and is managing a
cinnabon in omaha but he's become
increasingly paranoid that someone's
going to discover him and indeed one day
someone does but it's not the cops or
the cartel it's just a dude who used to
live in albuquerque and recognized him
from his commercials but saul freaks out
he calls the vacuum cleaner identity
changing guy like hey i need to change
again but then he's like you know what
never mind i'm gonna handle it so now
back in the past jimmy mcgill has just
gotten his law license back and he's
excited to start a new practice
representing the criminals that he's
been selling burner phones to because
they're all gonna need a lawyer sooner
or later only problem is they know him
as saul goodman and so it's happening
jimmy gets his doing business ads and
saul goodman's reached his final form he
hosts a big event to rebrand himself as
a lawyer and gives out his last batch of
phones with his number on speed dial he
gets a little carried away though and
offers 50 off legal fees which you know
might encourage people to commit crimes
now jimmy's girlfriend kim wexler is
mostly supportive of this it's awkward
though she just bought him a briefcase
with jimmy mcgill's initials and an even
better gift his iconic world's second
best lawyer thermos but now let's check
in with the cartel nacho is still
running things up here under the
supervision of lalo salamanca who is
kind of a micromanager but lalo's main
priority is his feud with gus fring at
the end of last season he was tailing
mike germantrout and almost discovered
the secret meth lab gus is building but
they come up with a good cover story and
everything settled for now the cartel
wants lalo to stop bothering gus because
gus is a big earner for them malala's
good friends with his uncle old man
hector salamanca and these two both hate
the chicken man as long as lalo's in
town it's too dangerous to continue
construction so they send all the
germans home but mike german trout feels
real bad now about having to kill their
leader who he was friends with he's like
hey gus i don't want to be a cartel
trigger man so he quits also secretly
working for gus fring is nacho varga who
gus is forcing to spy on lalo under
threat of killing his father he's like
hey you need to make lalo trust you and
soon nacho finds a way when their drug
house is found by the cops they're gonna
seize a whole load of drugs but nacho
goes jumps from the roof busts in their
batman style and gets out without the
cops finding he just saved the cartel a
ton of money and lala's like yo you're
loco man i like you but one of their
guys was caught crazy eight going to
jail so nacho goes to his favorite
lawyer saul goodman now jimmy doesn't
want to work with the cartel again in
season one tuko salamanca almost killed
him in the desert but lalo is a much
friendlier easygoing guy and working for
the cartel pays very well so saul
goodman's on the job but lalo doesn't
want him to get crazy eight out he wants
him to snitch specifically on gus
fring's side of the operation and now
coming in to take this case from
breaking bad it's hank schrader of the
dea and also of course his partner steve
gomez it all goes according to plan
nacho warns gus but he can't move his
cash without tipping his hand so he
takes a pretty big hit meanwhile mike
german trout starts drinking again and
picks a fight with some ruffians who
stab him he wakes up not in a hospital
but in a beautiful casita down in mexico
it's gus fring's secret sanctuary it's
like yo mike i need you mike still
doesn't want to work for the cartel but
gus friend's like yo i kill people for
business the salamancas kill people for
fun we are not the same and ultimately
what mike cares about most is providing
for his granddaughter so he's back on
team frank now kim wesler's career is
going great she gets to spend a lot of
time doing what she loves helping out
pro bono clients but it is the bank mesa
verde that pays the bills and they're
trying to build a new call center which
would involve kicking this old man off
his land now kim doesn't think of
herself as a heartless high-powered
lawyer who's about to kick an old man
off his land so a bank can build a call
center but she kinda is now kim goes to
mesa verde like hey you own the lot down
the street just build the call center
there but the bank doesn't go for it kim
has a bit of a crisis she brings in
jimmy like hey i need your special
skills for this so when they come to
evict this guy saul goodman is now his
lawyer and pulls a stunt where he
changes the address which will take a
day to clear up but the next day he
scattered broken pottery around which
might be native american artifacts and
will take a day to clear up and every
day there's something new that's gonna
cost him another day but mesa verde is
still not backing down so jimmy pulls
out the big guns doing what he does best
making cheesy commercials but now kim
pulls the plug like hey we gave it a
good go but it's time to admit defeat
but jimmy goes behind her back and
continues the plan he's this close he
can't let go he's made a whole series of
cheesy commercials with ridiculous
claims that will never hold up in court
but that'll take time to disprove and by
then they'll have already aired
tarnishing mesa verde's good name so
finally kevin's had enough he gives in
makes a handshake deal with jimmy to let
the guy keep his land so jimmy's all
excited they won but kim's like yo jimmy
you played me he's like i'm sorry baby i
hid it from you to protect you legally
and she's like i can't live with this if
i can't trust you so this might be it
the final straw where kim dumps him or
if they get married then they can share
everything and have spousal privilege so
their vows are to tell each other
everything especially jimmy when you
don't want to so kim and jimmy have
their cute courthouse ceremony and are
set to live happily ever after except of
course it's a prequel show we know they
don't what terrible fate awaits them now
with mike germain trout back on team
frank he pulls his own magic to get the
cops onto lalo's trail for the guy he
killed last season and soon lalo's
arrested he has a fake identity though
they don't know they've got a cartel
leader saul goodman's work in his legal
defense but it's like don't worry about
that just get me out on bail and i'll go
home to mexico if you get me out you'll
be a friend of the cartel which means
mucho dinero now lalo can still run
things from prison in fact he wants
nacho to burn down those spoils hermanos
of course he tells gus and so it's gus
fring himself who sets the frozen turkey
deep fryer timer which gives you just
enough time to make it across the street
and not look back at the explosion like
a badass so mike goes to see his old
friend jimmy like hey my boss wants lalo
out on bail and back to mexico too so
jimmy hires a fake family to prove he's
not the flight risk and the judge agrees
to set bail but mostly as a joke because
he makes it seven million dollars turns
out though for lalo that's no big deal
he just needs saul to go pick it up
jimmy knows he should say no but he'd do
it for a cool hundred grand and lalo's
like no problemo so jimmy drives out to
the middle of nowhere where he meets
lalo's cousins the murder twins who give
him the money without saying much so
this was the easiest hundred grand
anyone's ever made until it's not armed
men show up and being a friend of the
cartel isn't helpful when you're on the
wrong side in a cartel war but oh what's
this there's a sniper who's here to save
jimmy oh it's a big fire fight in the
end jimmy's guy wins and it is old man
my german trout who just came down to
make sure it went smoothly the cars are
all shot only jimmy still runs but it
doesn't last long because it was shot
too and they've got to abandon it in the
desert and walk home on foot an
extraordinarily long walk home through
some of the harshest terrain on earth it
is a grueling episode that really makes
you feel how difficult this is soon they
run out of water it's like hey if you're
thirsty drink your own piss eventually
jimmy's ready to give up but mike
germantrout gives him the pep talk they
gotta keep going one of the guys from
the shootout got away in a working
vehicle if they can snipe him maybe they
can take it but how now the car ends up
totaled and all his water was lost too
so finally jimmy has no choice haha
gross eventually they make it home alive
and jimmy hands over seven million
dollars in bail which raises some red
flags but lalo will be long gone by the
time they figure it out now mike was not
supposed to be there so jimmy needs a
cover story he's like yeah my car just
broke down had to walk back lala's like
wow man you really went the extra mile
i'm gonna leave you a five star yelp
review by the way who was trying to
steal the money turns out it was just
the other cartel guy who thought keeping
lalo in prison would end his feud with
gus
thanks man now jimmy does not tell kim
the full story of how close he came to
death but she realizes when she finds
the bullet holes in his thermos she
doesn't push him about it though because
jimmy is clearly scarred when she's back
at work doing boring bank stuff almost
losing jimmy puts into perspective
what's really important in life so she
quits her high paying job at a
prestigious firm abandons mesa verde to
do pro bono work full time so lalo
salamanca is heading back to mexico
except he has a last minute change of
heart because he realizes if saul
goodman just had random car trouble why
is his car in a ditch and covered in
bullet holes so he shows up at jimmy and
kim's apartment like hey tell me the
story again jimmy sticks to the story
but lalo keeps asking to hear it again
and even though he's still friendly the
threat of murder is tangible in the air
finally he's like yo i saw the bullet
holes and it's kim who steps up and
takes a big bluff she's like look this
is new mexico you leave a car on the
side of the road someone's gonna shoot
it up she really lets him have it and
this could go either way but kim doesn't
crack so lalo believes him for now so
jimmy and kim narrowly avoided death
they decided to take a little staycation
and now it's time to go back and talk
about an ongoing mini plot this season
with jimmy's old rival howard hamlin he
feels bad now about how he treated jimmy
it's like hey i should have stood up for
you against your brother chuck so he now
offers jimmy a job at hamline hamlin
mcgill yeah howard's trying to be a
better person but this rubs jimmy the
wrong way so he goes and throws bowling
balls at his car and continues messing
with him like sending prostitutes to
interrupt his business lunch finally
howard's like i'm sorry if i offended
you jimmy i was just trying to be nice
and jimmy's like yo it's laughable that
you think i want your pity and he
launches into what i would call an epic
unhinged rant howard goes to kim like yo
i think jimmy needs help but kim just
laughs she's fully on jimmy's side so
now in their hotel room they're having
fun talking up ways to mess with howard
like putting nair in his shampoo bottle
but then kim's like what if we went
after his career like framed him for
doing some malpractice actually that
would force them to settle the sandpiper
case yeah the big case with the old
folks home that's he's been working on
since the beginning if they settle now
jimmy would get about two million
dollars but that'd be going too far i
mean they're just joking around but
kim's like wait i mean are we joking
jimmy's like yo we'd have to set howard
up for doing something unforgivable it
would ruin his life like you're not
willing to do that are you but kim's
like hey i think i might be so watch out
for that meanwhile lalo goes home to
mexico where he's got a nice happy
compound and he decided to bring nacho
with him like hey man you deserve a
promotion they go to the never-ending
cartel pool party and meet the big
leader donna lario it's like hey man
this is nacho he's super cool and the
don takes a liking to him so good for
nacho except nacho still caught in this
double agent crossfire in fact gus
frings planning to assassinate lalo
tonight a few times this season nacho's
like yo mike i've done good work for you
please let my dad off the hook and mike
agrees he goes to gus like nacho's done
enough but gus fring does not agree so
he gets a secret call open the back door
at midnight but guess who can't sleep
tonight lalo's right there having a beer
nacho's got to improvise i'll get us
some tequilas then oils up a pan to
smoke up the kitchen so when lalo runs
off to see who burn the pizza rolls
nacho goes and opens the gate to let the
death squad in this should have been a
nice easy job but lalo gets lucky then
more than luck he goes into beast mode
he's got a secret bathtub escape tunnel
and crawls his way to freedom but when
the death squad goes to follow him oh he
came back to the house gets behind him
and takes him all out he makes him radio
in that the job's done but there's no
need for an interrogation cause he knows
this was gus frank and with his new best
friend nacho suspiciously absent he
knows he betrayed him too all season
long we've only seen smiling lalo but
he's not smiling anymore so lalo
salamanca is coming for vengeance and
that's how better call saul season 5
comes to an end
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and movies
[Music]